[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا انها الساعه ستون ساعه
الايقاع السريع والمختلف والمعلومات
المباشره والوافيه وفيها الكثير البدايه
من العناوين
العلاقه بين مصر وايران قد تصل الى تطبيع
بتجاوز المعوقات
بعد تجسس دام عشرين عاما كيف قطعت
الولايات المتحده راس الافعى الروسيه
وايضا في ملفات الساعه 60
ميزانيته اسرائيل الجديده هل جعلت حكومه
نتنياهو مستقره ام باتت حملا يسقط
تويتر يقلق اوروبا اكثر واكثر بقرار مفاجئ
فكيف ستحمي بروكسيل نفسها من المعلومات
المضلله
[موسيقى]
كان عام
1979 فارقا في العلاقات بين مصر وايران
كانت العلاقه بارده لكنها منذ ذلك التاريخ
تحولت الى ناحيه العداء واستمرت على هذا
النحو منذ ذلك الوقت على مدى العقود
الماضيه بدايه اعمى
1979 اندلعت الثوره الايرانيه بقياده ايه
الله الخميني الرئيس المصري انذاك محمد
انور السادات كان موقفه واضحا استقبل
السادات وقتها شاه ايران محمد رضا بهلوي
الذي لجا الى مصر بعد رفض غالبيه الدول
ايواء
لكن دي معركه لما بعثت لشائرا ام حول
المراكب من البحر تيجي على اسكندريه اللي
كانت رايحه اوروبا
حولها باللاسلكي على اسكندريه
[موسيقى]
وبعد مرور ثلاثه اشهر نحن في السادس
والعشرين من مارس
1979 وقعت مصر واسرائيل اتفاقيات كام
ديفيد لتقرر طهران وقتها قطع العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه مع مصر العام التالي لم يكن
مختلفا ارتفعت معه حده الخلافه بين
البلدين بسبب الحرب الايرانيه العراقيه
مصر رفضت الوقوف ضد بغداد ولان مواقف
السادات كانت مناهضه للخميني وبعد اغتيال
رئيس المصري عام
1981 اطلقت السلطات الايرانيه اسم المتهم
بقتله خالد الاسلامبولي على شارع في طهران
وما تسبب في استمرار الخلاف حتى الان
انيران وفي ايران كذلك وجدوا ذات الامر
ويرجع ذلك اساسا الى ان الخميني تعرض
لمعامله سيئه للغايه في العراق قبل
مغادرته فرنسا وارسله صدام حسين الى فرنسا
بناء على طلب شاه ايران
العداء والقطيعه الطويله قد تكون في
طريقها للزوال فخلال الاشهر الماضيه ظهرت
اشارات ايجابيه بين القاهره وطهران وزير
الخارجيه المصري سامح شكري التقى نائب
الرئيس الايراني علي سلاجقه في نوفمبر
الماضي على هامش مؤتمر المناخ كوب 27 في
شرم الشيخ وفي الشهر التالي التقى الرئيس
المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي بوزير الخارجيه
الايراني حسين امير عبد الله على هامشي
مؤتمر بغداد اثنين الذي اقيم في الاردن
وتوالى بعدها عدد من التصريحات لمسؤولين
ايرانيين اشاروا الانفتاح طهران على
مفاوضات عوده العلاقات مع مصر حسين امير
عبد الحي
حسنا اولا وقبل كل شيء هناك مكاتب حمايه
مصالح البلدين في طهران والقاهره وعلى راس
هذه المكاتب من الجانبين هناك شخص على
مستوى سفير لذلك توجد قناه رسميه للتواصل
والاتصال بيننا مباشره بالطبع بذلت بعض
الدول بعض الجهود لتشجيع مصر وحتى جمهوريه
ايران الاسلاميه على رفع مستوى العلاقات
بين البلدين
اذا هناك دول تحاول التوسط بين مصر وايران
عمان الوسيط الاول فمسقط ضربتها علاقته
وثيقه مع ايران وهي من توسطت بين طيران
والدول الكبرى في الاتفاق النووي عام 2015
في يوليو من العام الماضي افاد موقع ان
كبير
المفوضين الايرانيين علي باقر زار سلطنه
عمان وناقش فكره الاتصالات بين طهران
والقاهره وقبل اسبوع زار سلطان عمان هيثم
بن طارق القاهره وكانت الزياره الاولى له
الى مصر منذ توليه المنصب قبل اكثر من
ثلاث سنوات ثم بعدها بايام زار طهران
والتقى بالمرشد الايراني علي خامنئي الذي
رحب خلال اللقاء باستئناف العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه مع القاهره
حول تطوير العلاقات مع مصر فانه هو مباشره
بعد تصريحات المرشد الاعلى امر الرئيس
وزاره الخارجيه باتخاذ التدابير اللازمه
لتوطيد وتطوير العلاقات ان شاء الله
العراق الوسيط الثاني رئيس وزراءها محمد
شياع السوداني اقترح اطلاق حوارا مصريا
ايراني في ديسمبر الماضي وهو مرحبا به
وزير الخارجيه الايرانيه حسين امير
تقارير عده ومنها ما نشر على صحيفه دنا
شانيل على لسان الدبلوماسيا عراقي اكد عقد
جوله محادثات في العراق لبحث القضايا
العالقه لكن رسميا الطرفانيا رغم ذلك نقلت
وكاله مهر الايرانيه عن عضو لجنه الامن
القومي والسياسه الخارجيه في البرلمان
الايراني في دحسين مالكي تاكيده ان جوله
محادثات جرت بالفعل
وفقا لوجهه نظر حكومه الدكتور الرئيسي ان
يتم تطوير العلاقات مع دول المنطقه ومع
مصر الشقيقه والصديقه كما نعطي الاولويه
للعلاقات مع هذا البلد في السياسه
الخارجيه لنشهد انفتاحا وكي تكون هناك
خطوات جديده ومتبادله
اذا ما هي الملفات العالقه بانتظار
تفاهمات والتي تعرقل تطور العلاقات في
مقدمه هذه الملفات الوجود العسكري
الايرانيه في المنطقه عبرت مصر عرفنيها
الشديد له اضافه الى ضروره اتخاذ خطوات
الايجابيه في الملف الفلسطيني وعلى كل
الوزير الخارجيه المصريه سامح شكريه تحدث
قبل اعوام عن العراقيل التي تواجهها
العلاقات بين البلدين
يعني طبعا السياسات اللي بتنتهج والسياسات
فيها توسع
ومحاوله فرض نفوذ وهيمنه في النطاق العربي
والتاثير على الاوضاع في الدول العربيه
شيء غير مقبول من قبل مصر ودائما كانت مصر
واضحه في ذلك نحن نرى دائما العلاقات يجب
ان تبنى على فكره الاحترام المتبادل وعدم
التدخل في الشؤون الداخليه وعدم التامر
وانما العمل في اطار المصالح المشتركه
بعيدا عن فكره الهيمنه او النفوس عندما
تقدر ايران بان هذا هو المسلك الصحيح هذا
يغير من
الحاله الحاليه التي نشهدها
بشان النقاط العالقه طالب الطهران بعقد
اجتماع امنيا سياسي مع القاهره يتم تحديده
خلال الفتره المقبله تسعى طهران لمعرفه
مطالب القاهره بشكل اكبر ولذلك تريد
اجتماعات مباشره وتشكيل لجنه من الطرفين
تكون وظيفتها وضع صيغه لاعاده العلاقات
ووضع البنود التي يتم الاتفاق عليها ورغم
ان القاهره نفط رسميا على لسان وزير
خارجيتها ما تردد عن وجود مسار مصري
ايراني لتطوير العلاقات لكن القاهره
منفتحه على الاشارات الايرانيه الايجابيه
لتطوير العلاقات واحدى هذه الاشارات جاءت
قبل ايام على لسان وزير الخارجيه الايراني
بالقاهره
ان موقف السيد السيسي من تطورات السنوات
الاخيره في المنطقه وخاصه محاربه داعش
والتطرف في حاله سوريا كان موقفا منطقيا
وصحيحا اشارات ايجابيه من طهران قابلتها
اخرى من القاهره وتحديدا في مارس الماضي
وفي ملف السياحه
[موسيقى]
هناك امور قد تعيق هذا التقدم في
المحادثات اسرائيل في الصوره صحيفه يدعو
تحرنوت الاسرائيليه اشارت الى ان حكومه
بنيامين نتنياهو ابلغت القاهره باستيائها
البالغ مما يتردد حول حدوث التطورات
ايجابيه في العلاقات بين القاهره والطيران
ورغم الخلافات الحاده بين الحكومه
الاسرائيليه والمعارضه وسنتوناول ذلك
بالتفصيل بعد قليل لكنهما في هذا الملف
متفقان التقارب المصري الايراني يتعارض مع
المصالح الاسرائيليه والاقليميه بحسب زعيم
المعارضه يا اغلابيد
[موسيقى]
ومن القاهره ينضم الينا عمرو الشوبك يا
مستشار في مركز الاهرام للدراسات السياسيه
والاستراتيجيه اهلا بك اذا الموقف
الايراني المتقدم الوساطه العمانيه وايضا
الجهود العراقيه كلها يعني تعيد اليوم
الطريق الى علاقات انقطعت منذ عقود ولكن
في هذا هذه الخطوات ما هي اهميه الاستئناف
للعلاقات وايضا كيف ستتجاوب مصر ما هو
قادم في ظل مطالبها وايضا في ظل الضغط
الاسرائيلي
اهميه استئناف هذه العلاقات هو نفس
الاهميه التي
اولادها كثير من دول المنطقه
في خلق علاقات
وفتحت قنوات اتصال مع دول كانت مختلفه
معها في التوجه
وحاله مصر ايضا مع تركيا
القنوات الاتصال التي فتحت بين المملكه
وبين ايران نفسها العلاقات التي عادت بين
الامارات
وايران ثم ايضا عوده سوريا الى جامعه
الدول العربيه والتي تعتبر كما هو معروف
حليف رئيسي لايران في المنطقه انا اعتقد
انه نحن امام ربما شكل جديد في اداره
العلاقات البينيه بين الدول العربيه
والدول
الاقليميه المجاوره الكبرى وتحديدا ايران
وتركيا والذي يعني ان عوده العلاقات او
تطبيع العلاقات لا يعني انتفاء الخلافات
حول بعض الملفات وفي ظل نمط التفاعلات
الاقليميه يعني هناك قراءه مصريه متانيه
امام هذا الاقبال الايراني ولكن في نفس
الوقت تصريحات خلينا يتحدثت عن جهود مصريه
يعني
الجهود انا اعتقد انها يعني متبادله يعني
وانه هناك رغبه في
ان تعود او ان تفتح قنوات اتصال وان تكون
هناك علاقات طبيعيه هذه العلاقات على كل
يعني
كان معروف من هو السفير المصري الذي كان
موجودا وقائم باعمال
مصر في ايران كان هناك قائم بالاعمال
الايراني في القاهره
لكن كان هناك تناقض في المواقف وكما جاء
في التقرير انه في اعقاب الثوره الايرانيه
في 79 كانت ايران تتحول جذريا نحو ما عرف
في
محور الممانعه وكانت مصر تتحول في عكس
الاتجاه في اتجاه محور الاعتدال
وبكل ما ترتب على ذلك من تناقضات
المشكله انه الجانب الايراني سعى الى
تصدير نموذجه السياسي يعني في كل بلاد
العالم هناك خلافات وهناك خبرات تاريخيه
مختلفه لكل نظام ولكل خبره سياسيه مختلفه
عن الاخر
ما سبب خشيه اسرائيل من هذا التقارب اعتبر
ان التقارب مؤشرا لامكانيه وجود نظام امني
يضم ايران تركيا ومصر ويهدد اسرائيل
وترفضه اسرائيل لماذا
يعني هي تخوفات اسرائيل في في كل شيء مصر
ليست جزء من سياسه المحاور في كل الاحوال
الملف النووي الايراني اسرائيل لديها خشيه
من ان توقع الولايات المتحده اتفاق مع
ايران ونعرف ان هناك اسباب كثيره لتعثر
هذا الاتفاق ولكن حتى اذا كان هذا الاتفاق
راى النور فالولايات المتحده قدمت اشارات
شديده الحده للحليف الرئيسي والاستراتيجي
لها وهو الولايات المتحده من اجل يعني
اعاقه التوقيع على هذا الاتفاق من هنا
التقارب المصري هو في جانب كبير منه هو
عوده للعلاقات الاقتصاديه شفنا انه اول
ملف مع الظروف الاقتصاديه التي تمر بها
مصر فتح هو ملف السياحه سيكون هناك يعني
عوده في اطار التحولات التي تشهدها
المنطقه
الاقليميه وضحت الصوره شكرا جزيلا لك كنت
معنا من القاهره عمرو الشوبكي مستشار في
مركز الاهرام للدراسات السياسيه
والاستراتيجيه
يقدم نفسه على انه ترامب لكن دون اخطائه
في الساعه بعد دقيقه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد من قال ان حرب التجسس
بين موسكو وواشنطن انتهت بنهايه الحرب
البارده تغير اسلوب التجسس واصطياد
المعلومات بتطور التكنولوجيا ولم يعد
مرتبطا باسماء جواسيس ولا عملاء منبسين
بقدر ارتباطه ببرامج التجسس جعلت من الامن
السيبراني اهم خطوط الدفاع عن الامن
القومي
منذ 20 عاما طورت روسيا نظاما الكترونيا
للتجسس اطلق عليه نظام الافعى الامريكيون
اشاعروا ان الكثير من اجهزه الكمبيوتر
الحكوميه مخترقه ولكن تفكيك اللغز استغرق
عقدين والكثير من الجهود وزاره العدل
الامريكيه كشفت التفاصيل برامج الافعى
تمكنت من اختراق حواسيب المسؤولين
الامريكيين اضافه الى قيادينا في 50 دوله
من حلفاء امريكا الاختراق الروسي ام يشمل
مدارس ومراكز ابحاث طريقه نقل المعلومات
ووصفت بالثوريه برنامج الافعى يخترق اجهزه
الكمبيوتر عبر تثبيت برامج مشبوهه يتم
التحكم بها عن بعد وغالبا ما يكون برنامجا
يرصد كل التحركات للوحه المفاتيح البرنامج
يسجل المعلومات في البدايه قبل ان ينقلها
في خوادم عبر دول مختلفه وقبل ارسالها الى
روسيا واشنطن حددت المكان مدينه ريزان
الجنوب موسكو وبالتحديد مقر فرقه التورلا
الروسيه للتجسس الالكتروني خبراء واشنطن
تتبع البرنامج منذ عقدين لكن المهمه كانت
صعبه فريق تورلا كان يرسل تحديثات
وتعديلات دوريه على البرنامج الذي صمد
لعشرين عاما
[موسيقى]
نجحت جهوده التخلص من الفيروس الذي اصاب
اجهزه الكمبيوتر التي تحفظ اسرار الاداره
الامريكيه لكن ميزه برامج الافعى التكمن
في قوتها على تحديث اساليبها وبرمجياتها
هنا لجات امريكا الى انشاء تحالف سمي
بوكاله الامن السيبراني للاعين الخمسه
والمقصود هنا اتحاد اجهزه الامن السيبراني
للولايات المتحده كندا بريطانيا استراليا
ونيوزيلندا العمليه اطلق عليها اسم قنديل
البحر وعمل التحالف الجديد على ابقاء امره
سرا حتى على الضحايا الذين تم اختراقهم
حتى لا يتفطن الروس ويغير التشفير الاعين
الخمسه تمكنت من تطوير برنامج قادر على
اجراء اتصالنا بنظام الافعى دون معرفه
الهويه ما مكنت تحالف من ارسال الاوامر
لتدمير الافعادون الاضرار باجهزه
الكمبيوتر وما تحتويه من بيانات
الغاء فاعليه النظام الروسي استهلك الكثير
من الجهد والوقت لكن حصيله 20 عاما من
التجسس كانت وفيره بالطبع حتى ان الاعين
الخمسه لا تعرف على ماذا حصلت روسيا او ان
كانت تستخدم الان نظاما اخر اكثر سريه
[موسيقى]
في مقابل الكشف الامريكي هناك كشف روسي
جهاز الامن الفيدرالي الروسي اعلن انه
اكتشف برنامجا امريكيا فائق التطور
استخدمته واشنطن لاختراق الاف اجهزه
الايفون في روسيا واشنطن وجدت الطريقه
الامثل لمراقبه علاقات كل الدول مع روسيا
وهي التجسس على الدبلوماسيين الاجانب في
روسيا العمليه شملت هواتف دول الاتحاد
السوفيتي السابق والصين الا ان التجسس لم
يستثني ممثلي دول الناتو ايضا ممن
يستخدمون هواتف ايفون لكن الامر الاكثر
خطوره بالنسبه لروسيا هم الاف المسؤولين
الذين يستخدمون الهواتف الامريكيه وهذه
هنا سوره
في بالي وزير الخارجيه الروسي يرتدي ساعه
ابل ويستخدم جهاز ايفون وهو ليس استثناء
فخمسه وعشرون مليون
يستخدمون منتجات ابل الامن الفيدرالي كشف
تفاصيل الاختراق وكان مساعده في ذلك شركه
كاسبرسكي الروسيه للحمايه السيبرانيه
[موسيقى]
وصفت بالاكثر تدميرا في تاريخ اسرائيل
وبالتالي اثارت غضب الكثيرين في الشارع
وفي المعارضه نتحدث هنا عن الميزانيه
الجديده لاسرائيل الميزانيه اقرها الكنيست
باغلبيه 64 نائبا من اصل 120 هم اعضاء
الكتله اليمنيه لنتنياهو بلغت الميزانيه
484 مليار شيكل لعام 2023 اي نحو 130
مليار دولار وفي عام 2024 ستكون الاكبر في
تاريخ اسرائيل ستزيد نصف ترليون شيكل لاول
مره بالمصادقه عليها ضمنه حكومه نتنياهو
استقرارا داخليا حيث اخضع رئيس الوزراء
لمساومات من قبل الاحزاب المتشدده في
الائتلاف الحكومي ولذلك كان نتنياهو سعيدا
ولا يوجد جدول الدينات الحكومه برئاسه
لديها اخبار رائعه لمواطني دوله اسرائيل
نجحنا بتمرير قانون الميزانيه لسنتي 2003
2024 ما يمنح الاستقرار والبناء لدولتنا
ويعطينا الاستقرار في السياسه لاربع سنوات
قادمه وهذا امر مهم
الاستقرار الذي وفرته الميزانيه لنتنياهو
غائب عن الشارع الاسرائيلي المنتفض منذ
فتره زعيم المعارضه يا ايرلابيد وصف
الميزانيه الجديده بالاسوا والاكثر تدميرا
في تاريخ اسرائيل وبالتالي انطلق
المتظاهرون في الشوارع للتعبير عن غضبهم
رؤوا في الميزانيه مهبل للدوله وتحديدا
فيما يتعلق بتخصيص مساعدات ماليه لليهود
المتشددين بمئات الملايين من الدولارات
واللافتات واضحه مشاهدينا كما نشاهد لن
ندعك تساعد في تدمير اسرائيل هذه رساله
المتظاهرين لينه ياهو
هذه اشكاليه كبيره الميزانيه تهدف الى
تقسيمنا لمنح المقربين من الحكومه اموالا
وليس للقطاعات الاخرى المحتاجه ليس للصحه
وليس للتعليم ولا للاكاديميه بل لادامتي
عدم المساواه
الميزانيه هائله فهي تمنح امتيازات
لقطاعات معينه ولا تاخذوا عامه السكان في
الاعتبار
الشارع الاسرائيلي اسبابه كثيره وطبعا
قانون التعديلات القضائيه وقوده تم تاجيله
فقط وليس الغائه تحت الضغوط وقوه الشارع
لكن اقرار الميزانيه يبدو انه منح نتنياهو
دفعه اضافيه اكد بعد الاقرار ان القانون
سيعود الى اجنده الحكومه
سنستمر بجهودنا من اجل الوصول الى توافق
كبير بما يتعلق بالاصلاح القضائي
تصريحاته استفزت المعارضه احد قادتها بني
جانس وهو وزير الدفاع السابق قال نصا اذا
عاد القانون
سنزلزل الدوله
وسنوقف مشروع التعديلات القضائيه هذه
الاحتجاجات ليست ملكا خاصا لي او لاي شخص
سياسي لا اعتقد ان المتظاهرين سيسمح لنا
او لنتنياهو باللعب معهم واعتقد ان ردهم
سيكون بشكل ملائم
ان كان اقرار الميزانيه منح نتنياهو دفعه
فكلمته جانس هذه مدفوعه بدعم الشارع
التظاهرات مستمره منذ خمسه اشهر حتى الان
والهتافات واحده
كل اسبوع ناتي لان هذا مهم لانه ليست
لدينا دوله اخرى لان الناس يحاولون
السيطره على نظامنا وتحويله الى شيء سيء
لفرض اشياء لا نؤمن بها مثل كراهيه
الاجانب وحرمان الاقليات من الحقوق لتغيير
ميزان كل ما هو موجود هنا وتدميري مستقبل
البلاد
الى هنا للتظاهر اسبوعيا في الشهرين او
الثلاثه اشهر الماضيه اتيت الى هنا نيابه
عني ونيابه عن والدي اريد ان احافظ على
هذا البلد بالطريقه التي تم تاسيسها بها
ويمكننا القيام بذلك معا
في الواقع هذا هو الاسبوع الحادي والعشرون
الذين ناتي فيه للتظاهر كل ليله السبت من
اجل مستقبل بلدنا والتظاهر من اجل
الديمقراطيه الاسرائيليه والتظاهر من اجل
مستقبل امتنا كدوله ديمقراطيه حره
التعديلات القضائيه وما تبعها من تظاهرات
تمثل خطرا كبيرا على الاقتصاد الاسرائيلي
قد يؤدي الى تشديد الاوضاع الماليه واعاقه
الاستثمار والنمو على المدى الطويل وهكذا
يرى صندوق النقد الدولي الوضع في تل ابيب
وجاء اقرار الميزانيه ليزيد منه صحيفه
ماركر الاقتصاديه الاسرائيليه وصفته بحكم
الاعدام على الاقتصاد الاسرائيلي هل هذا
وصف مبالغ فيه لا يبدل الامر كذلك فوكاله
موديز الشهر الماضي خفض التوقعات التصنيف
الائتماني السيادي لاسرائيل من ايجابي الى
مستقر كما ان التوقعات تشير الى ان نمو
الناتج المحلي الاجمالي لاسرائيل سيتباطى
الى اثنين فاصله خمسه في المئه في 2023
مقارنه ب
6.5% في 2022
[موسيقى]
كل هذه التحذيرات ياتي تقرير اخر ليزيد
الانتقادات الموجهه لحكومه نتنياهو رئيس
الوزراء انفقه على منزله حينما شغل المنصب
من قبل اضعاف انفاق رئيسي الوزراء
السابقين
بنات مجتمعين خلال نفس المده هذا التقرير
صادر من مكتب رئاسه الوزراء بناء على طلب
حركه حريات المعلومات في اسرائيل والتي
تاسست عفوا عام 2004 من قبل حقوقيين
وقانونيين وبحسب التقرير انفق بنت الذي
تولى رئاسه الوزراء في الفتره من يونيو
2021 وحتى يونيو 2022 ولقيد الذي تولى
بعده المنصب في الفتره من يوليو وحتى
ديسمبر عام 2022 انفق اقل من مليون شيكل
اي نحو 285 الف دولار في عام واحد بينما
زادت نفقات نتنياهو عن اربعه ملايين شيكل
مليون ومئه الف دولار خلال السنه الواحده
ورغم ان ارقامه اقل منه لكن بنات نفسه كان
قد تعرض لانتقادات حينما كان رئيسا
للوزراء بسبب هذه النفقات التي تتحملها
الدوله يخرج وقتها ويعلن انه سيدفع فاتوره
طعام عائلته من جيبه الخاص
[موسيقى]
نيويورك تغرق ببطء بسبب الثقل مبانيها في
الساعه بعد دقيقه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد بدايه صعبه شاهدها اعلان
وروندي سانتوس عن ترشحه لمصب الرئاسه
الامريكيه في اطار استراتيجيه تجاهل وسائل
الاعلام الرئيسيه التقليديه بشكل كبير
واسئله الصعبه وبعد ترويج كبير لاعلانه
اكثر من 600 الف مستخدم لتويتر قضاء خمسه
عشره دقيقه من الاخطاء التقنيه لسماع
المحادثه بين ديسانتس ومالك تويتر ايلون
ماسك
حاول تدارك الموقف
انا حاكم فلوريدا رونديس انا مترشح لرئاسه
الولايات المتحده لقياده عوده بلادنا
العظيمه على ان ذلك عبر منصه المساحات
الصوتيه على تويتر في وقت سابق الليله
وحطمن الارقام القياسيه على انترنت لان
اشخاص كثيرين تحمسوا لسماع الاعلان
قبل اشهر بدا ديسانس المرشح الجمهوري
الاوف يزال تحقيق وثائق منتجع ماريلاجو
وظهر الشاب الايطالي الاصل في صوره
شابه واكثر حماسه اليوم انقلبت الصوره
ترامب يتفوق بنسبه 20% عن ملاحقه ديسانس
في استطلاعات الراي وهناك اسباب عده
والسبب الاول حرب اوكرانيا
ديسانس اعتبر ان الحرب الاوكرانيه تخص
اوروبا وحدها خصومه اعتبره بالانعزالي
وذلك في وقت قال فيه ترامب انه يستطيع وقف
هذه الحرب خلال اربع وعشرين ساعه سبب اخر
اتهم ديسانتوس بانه مناهض للشركات بسبب
معاركه مع شركه ديزني ترامب جاء في صف
الشركه وراى انها تسحق ديسانتوس وضربه
الاخيره كانت في يد ديسانتوس نفسه وقع على
قرار بحظر الاجهاض بعد سته اسابيع من
الحمل في سلوريد ا قرار وصفه ترامب
للمتطرف خصوصا وان غالبيه الجمهوريين
يؤيدون فتره السته اشهر بحسب استطلاعات
الراي
بلدنا يسير في الاتجاه الخاطئ يمكننا ان
نرى الامر وان نشعر به لقد انهارت حدودنا
الجنوبيه تمتلك عصابات المخدرات المكسيكيه
سيطره اكبر على ما يجري على الحدود اكثر
من حكومتنا في الولايات المتحده الملايين
من الاجانب غير الشرعيين تدفقوا الى
بلادنا
الاكبر في ضروره اقناع قاعده ترامب
الشعبيه بانه يمثل نسخه اكثر التزاما
وانضباطا من الرئيس السابق منافسه رئاسيه
ثالثه وهي نيكي هيلي تحدثت عن الامر حمله
ديسانس كلها قائمه على تقليد ترامب لدرجه
ان حمله هذه نشرت فيديو يوضح اوجه الشبه
بين ترامب وديسانس
[موسيقى]
امريكا
يقدم المرشح الجمهوري رونالدو
مثل ترامب لكن من دون اخطائه وانه يمتلك
سجلا حافلا بانجازات متعلقه بقيم محافظه
حققها خلال مسيرته السياسيه كتسهيل امتلاك
السلاح وتقييد تعليم الهويه الجنسيه في
المدارس وتشديد قواعد التصويت في
الانتخابات والحد من عمليات الاجهاض ويركز
ديسنتس على انه يفوز دائما ويشير الى انه
لم يهزم في سباقات الكونجرس او منصب حاكم
فلوريدا ويرفض ما يصفها بثقافه الخساره
التي اثرت على الحزب الجمهوري في السنوات
الاخيره معتبرا ان وقت الاعذار قد ولى
مزايا تجعل نظريا على الاقل مرشحا يمكنه
التغلب على ترامب المتقدمه على جميع
المرشحين الجمهوريين حاليا
باي باي بيردي بهذه الكلمات الساخره
انتقدت نائبه رئيس المفوضيه الاوروبيه
للقيم والشفافيه فيرا فيرا جروبا حراره
منصه تويتر بالانسحاب من قانون مكافحه
التظليل في الاتحاد الاوروبي لكن اين قامت
بالانتقاد على تويتر القانون الذي تتحدث
عنه النائبه وقعت عليه منصات عده متى جوجل
تويتر ومايكروسوفت وبموجبه ستكون هذه
الشركات ملتزمه بدءا من الخامس والعشرين
من اغسطس المقبل بمواجهه المعلومات
المضلله لكن ما معنى ذلك هل يستطيع تويتر
الان التخلص من التزاماته بعد قرار
الانسحاب
وفوض الصناعه الاوروبيه تاري بريتون اجاب
لا وشبه الامر بانه يمكن الربط ولكن لا
يمكن الاختباء
[موسيقى]
اطلقت اوروبا هذا القانون من اجل الحد من
المعلومات والبيانات المضلله المعلومات
والبيانات مهمه اهم حتى من النفط لانها
مورد متجدد بوصف
نائبه الرئيس التنفيذي للمفوضيه الاوروبيه
والمسؤوله عن اوروبا ملائمه للعصر الرقمي
ولذلك اطلقت اوروبا قانون مكافحه التظليل
الذي انسحب منه موقع تويتر فما هي تبعات
هذا الانسحاب قد يتم حظر المنصه في اوروبا
ربما رساله ضمنيه لبقيه المواقعين على
الميثاق اكثر من 16 مليون متابعا لتويتر
في فرنسا قد يحرمون من استخدام حساباتهم
على المنصه المثيره للجدل فاعتبارا من
الخامس والعشرين من اغسطس من العام الجاري
سيحضر تويتر في اوروبا ولن يغرد في فرنسا
مره اخرى بعد هذا التاريخ في حال لم يلتزم
بقواعد الاتحاد الاوروبي هذا القرار ياتي
على خلفيه اعلان المنصه الانسحاب من مدونه
الاتحاد الاوروبي للممارسات السليمه ضد
تضليل الاعلامي عبر الانترنت لكن رغبه
اداره تويتر في التملص بشكل رئيسيا من
واجبها في ازاله المحتوى غير القانوني
وحظر الاعلان الذي يستهدف القاصرين قد
يعرضها لدفع غرامات ماليه تصل الى سته في
المئه من حجم الاعمال لتؤدي في نهايه
المطاف الى اختفاء المنصه في الفضاء
الاوروبي
انسحبت فطر اذا من الميثاق ليزيد القلق
خاصه وان عددا من الدول ستشهد انتخابات
الفتره المقبله لكن هذا القلق موجود اصلا
من وقت تولي ماسك اطلق ماسك الاشتراك
الشهري للمستخدمين ليحصلوا على علامه
التحقق امر استغله البعض اشتروا العلامات
ونشروا المعلومات المضلله وفقا لمنظمه
قام ماسك باعاده تفعيل
6700 حساب كانت قد علقت بسبب الانتهاكات
لكن هذا العدد الفعلي ربما يكون اكثر
بكثير المبرمج المقيم في المانيا ترابس
براون جمع قائمه تضم اكثر من 67 الف حساب
على تويتر اعيد تفعيلها منذ استحواذ ماسك
على المنصه وبالتالي زادت المعلومات
المضلله لكن ما هو رد ماسك
حسنا هل تعرف من يقول ان شيئا ما هو
معلومات مضلله من هو الحكم على ذلك حسنا
اذا يجب ان تكون قد رايت في بعض النقاط
معتقدت انه محتوى كراهيه
انا اسال عن مثال واحد لا يمكن اعطائي
مثالا واحدا
امثله
وفرنسا ردت المنشورات المناهضه للقاحات
والمنشورات الداعمه لما يسمى بالنازيين
الجدد والمؤمنين بتفوق العرق الابيض رابطه
مكافحه التشهير ايدي ال نشرت تحقيقا هي
الاخرى ردت قرار ماسك خلق مساحاتنا لنشر
نظريات المؤامره وانواع اخرى من الكراهيه
المنشورات الخاصه بنظريه المؤامره التي
اختلقها اليمين الامريكي زادت بنسبه واحد
وتسعين في المئه بين مايو 2022 ومايو من
هذا العام الحالي نشرت ثلاثه ارباع هذه
الرساله بعد استحواذ ماسك
[موسيقى]
من لندن ينضم الينا عبر سكايب اياد بركات
خبير وسائط التواصل الاجتماعي والامن
السيبراني اهلا بك بعد انسحاب تويتر من
الميثاق هل فعلا يخاطر تخاطر المنصه
بفقدان اكثر من 440 الف مستخدم اوروبي
نعم هذا قد يحدث طبعا الميثاق التي الذي
انسحبت منه شركه تويتر هو كان ميثاق تطوعي
قامت العديد من الشركات مئات من الشركات
بالتوقيع عليه لطمانه الاتحاد الاوروبي
لكي لا يقوم بتن قوانين قويه ولكن الاتحاد
الاوروبي لم يتوقفه بالفعل سوف يبدا
القانون الرقمي الجديد للاتحاد الاوروبي
ويدخل حيز التنفيذ في بعد شهرين من الان
وسوف يكون يعني هناك امكانيه واداء
قانونيه بيد الاتحاد الاوروبي لفرض غرامات
تصل الى سته بالمئه من الدخل العالمي لاي
شركه نعم وهذا وهذا بالطبع يشمل الشركات
المواقع نتحدث عن ميته ومايكروسوفت وكانت
تويتر قبل الانسحاب وشركات اخرى يعني ملفت
جدا قال مفوض الصناعه الاوروبيه يعني انه
لا يمكن الهروب من هذا الميثاق وانه ولكن
لا يمكنك الاختباء كيف يمكن ملاحقه تويتر
بعد الانسحاب من الميثاق
الميثاق كان مثاقا تطوعيا ولكن القانون
بعد شهرين سوف يصبح قانون يعني يمكن
للاتحاد الاوروبي ان يلاحق هذه الشركات
سواء كانت تويتر او غيرها في محاكم
الاتحاد الاوروبي وهم اعلنوا ايضا منذ
يومين ان فرقهم القانونيه جاهزه لملاحقه
التويتر وبعد اسبوعين او ثلاث اسابيع من
الان سوف يكون هناك جلسات حتى قبل بدء
تطبيق هذا القانون سوف يكون هناك جلسه
تحقيق مع تويتر مع الشركه نفسها لكي ترى
يرى الاتحاد الاوروبي ان كانت هذه الشركه
ملتزمه سواء بالميثاق التطوعي السابق او
بالقوانين التي سوف تاتي بعد بعد شهرين
وما سيزيد هذه الازمه ان المدير مدير
المحتوى في تويتر استقاله منذ يومين وهذا
سيضع شركه تويتر في ازمه كبيره
دعني سيد اياد دعني اشير الى هذه النقطه
هناك
عن الاكاديميه الوطنيه للعلوم تقول ان
تصميم مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي وهذه
المنصات تسمح بكل الاحوال بانتشار
المعلومات
المضلله بالتالي المساله ليست تويتر وايضا
قد يكون ميثاق غير كافر لمنع المعلومات
المضلله بهذا الشكل خاصه وايضا ان الميثاق
يعني يوجه له انتقادات بانه لم يوظف العدد
لم توظف اوروبا العدد الكافي لمهمه
المراقبه فيه
نعم يعني
مشكله شبكات التواصل الاجتماعي قديمه جدا
وهي مصممه بالاساس خوارزمياتها مصممه لكي
تزيد من التفاعل على حساب الحقيقه هي لا
تهتم في اغلب الاحيان ان كان المنشور
حقيقي او ان كان منشور لا يحتوي على على
نظريات مؤامره واخبار مطبركه فقط تهتم في
اغلب الاحيان ان كان هناك تفاعل مع هذا
المنشور فهي مصممه لمضاعفه وزياده انتشار
الاخبار سواء الكاذبه او غير كاذبه المهم
هو التفاعل بالنسبه لهذه الشركات وضحت
الفكره شكرا لك من لندن عبر سكايب اياد
بركات خبير وسائط التواصل الاجتماعي
والامن السيبراني
[موسيقى]
مدينه نيويورك بدات تغرق بالفعل وقريبا قد
يكون تمثال الحريه الشهير مجرد ذكرى كلمات
صادمه بالتاكيد لكنها الحقيقه حسب دراسه
نشرت على مجله
فما السبب في هذا الامر
ارتفاعه مستوى البحر حول المدينه باكثر من
ضعف المعدل العالمي ويتوقع حدوث ذلك بحلول
عام
2050 وبما بين ثماني بوصات وثلاثين بوصه
السبب الثاني هو وزن مبانيها الكلي لتقريب
الصوره اكثر الباحثون حسب كتله اكثر من
مليون مبنى في الاحياء الخمسه لمدينه
نيويورك والاستنتاج كان ان هذه المباني
تزن ما يعادل
762 مليار كيلوغرام ولمعرفه مدى الكارثه
مشاهدينا هذا الوزن يعادل تقريبا مليونير
طائره بوينج من طراز
بل ومحمله بالكامل لا يشمل هذا الرقم
بالطبع البنيه التحتيه لوسائل النقل التي
تربط المدينه ولا نحو ثمانيه ملايين ونصف
المليون شخص يسكنها المعدل المتوسط لغرق
المنطقه ومبانيها هو من بلي متر واحد الى
مليمترين سنويا لكن مناطق من حاتم بروكلين
وكوينز ستغرق بمعدل اسرع من المتوسط اربعه
مليمترات السنويا هي الاكثر حيويه
واكتضاضا بالطبع لكن نيويورك ليست وحدها
في هذا الخطر امستردام البصره البندقيه
وبانكوك مدن اخرى تواجه هذا الخطر
لم قدمه اي انسان كوكب المريخ على الاطلاق
لكن الان ولاول مره بامكاننا رؤيه الكوكب
بشكل مباشر وكاله الفضاء الاوروبيه اي اس
اي اطلقت بثا مباشرا على موقع يوتيوب من
الان وحتى الساعه المقبله انا حنين
الشويلي وهذه الساعه 60
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات